ساتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع جورجيا
الانتخابات في جورجيا هذا العام لها
خصوصيه شديده فكما نرى قد تحسم الولايه
الاغلبيه لاحد الحزبين في مجلس الشيوخ بين
المرشحين الجمهوري هيرشل ووكر وديمقراطي
رافاييل وورد ايضا لنفس الولايه تاثير
كبير على نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه فالفائز بها يحصل على 16 صوتا
في المجمع الانتخابي وهذا مهم جدا هذه
مشاهدين ايضا خريطه نتائج انتخابات في
ولايات الجنوب الشرقيه عام 2016 كانت بين
هلالك كلينتون ودونالد ترامب ايضا كما نرى
ذهبت جميعها الى المرشح الجمهوري انا ذاك
الرئيس السابق ترامب هذه الخريطه ايضا
تظهر الان نتائج الولايات في خابات عام
2020 كانت طبعا بين الجو بايدن وترامب كل
هذه الولايات ذهبت لترامب لذلك نراها
حمراء ما عدا جورجيا هو الامر الذي لم
يصدقه ترامب واكد وجود تزوير في نتائج هذه
الولايه بالتحديد من ابرز العوامل التي
تسببت بهذه النتيجه ما هي اولا جهود
الديمقراطيه السيسي ابرامز المرشحه
الديمقراطيه لمنصب حاكم جورجيا في سباق
الانتخابات الحاليه السيسي ابرامز من هي
خاضت السباق على منصب حاكم جورجيا امام
برايم كامل في عام 2018 لكنها في وقتها
خسرت نفس السباق يتكر بين الاثنين هذه
الانتخابات ايضا حينما خسرت السيسي انشئت
مركزا لتشكيل الناخبين من ذوي الاصول
الافريقيه في كسوف الانتخابات ليكون قوه
فا لا الديمقراطيين وبالفعل مشاهدينا نجحت
في تسجيل
800,000 ناخذ جديد يعتقد ان هذه الاصوات
التي سجلتها ابرامز هي التي تسببت بفوز
الجوبيدن بولايه جورجيا في الانتخابات عام
[موسيقى]